car confessions okay so I just have to
tell you I am dating someone exclusively
just he's absolutely a dream come true
ah so excited sister wife star Christine
Brown is officially off the market as
she reveals she has a boyfriend
following her split from ex-husband Cody
I'm dating just for fun yeah and just
months after Christine told E.T she's
dating it seems things got serious she
gushed all about her new bow in this car
confessional he's
wonderful and romantic and so kind and
everything I've been looking for
incredible with truly I'm just he's
absolutely a dream come true and I'm so
excited to show you guys pictures and
everything in a little bit right now I'm
just keeping him to myself though and I
will let you guys know a little bit more
information later but just ah so excited
after everything you've been through
what is it you're looking for in a new
partner
um kindness
um real just kindness and romantic
relationship for sure someone's who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that just last week Christine admitted
she was a bit nervous putting herself
back out there she and Cody were
spiritually married for more than 25
years before she called it quits
it's okay for me to move on yeah it's a
it's a real paradigm shift for me
and I'm sitting here
wondering if I'm making a mistake
making a mistake in how what do you mean
we're leaving Christine wrote alongside
these picks I'm dating again holy hell
awkward dating online is crazy and asked
any advice we're dating at 50 you know
that just keeping everything super light
because that's just who I am right now
I'm just gonna keep everything like
Christine isn't the only former wife of
Cody moving on and as for me lately I've
been focusing Less on doing what they
say I can't do and more on doing
whatever the hell I want Mary Brown is
all smiles while riding a canoe with a
friend and if that audio sounds familiar
it's Taylor Swift's acceptance speech
from the 2019 billboard women in Music
Awards and as for me lately I've been
focusing Less on doing what they say I
can't do and more on doing
whatever the hell I want yeah and it
seems Mary's sharing about how she's
choosing to live her life now the
caption building businesses building
friendships building a great life all
while doing whatever the hell I want
[Music]
foreign